our new playing cards are curious and a  piping hot stew of illusion  put them together to create mind-bending  juare patterns if you're a curiosity box  subscriber or become one soon you'll be  getting these let's do some math magic  with them deal out three piles of three  cards each choose any pile and then  choose a card from that pile let's  choose the nine of clubs place the card  you chose at the bottom of its pile and  then place that pile on top of the other  two piles now we're gonna spell the name  of the card we picked letter by letter  dealing down one card for each letter  just like this  n i n e rest on top  o  f  rest on top  c l u b s  rest on top now no matter what card you  chose the card you chose will now be the  fifth card from the top of the deck  as always thanks for nine of clubs